pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec béatrice brugère secrétaire général
adjoint du syndicat national des
magistrats est faux bond soir béatrice
brugère merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france vous comprenez cette
recadrage de la cour de cassation envers
le président de la république je sais
pas si on peut parler de recadrage que
l'on peut dire d'abord que c'est une
communication de la cour de cassation
qui est quand même à cela donc il faut
la prendre aussi comme test à dire
qu'elle est importante elle est courte
vue elle est lapidaire et qu'est ce
qu'elle dit elle dit elle rappelle tout
simplement nos institutions dans nos
institutions pour la france en tout cas
en ce qui concerne la france le
président de la république est garant de
l'indépendance de la justice et c'est
extrêmement important c'est à dire que
en fait comme il est garant de cette
indépendance
il ne peut prendre position sur tout sur
une affaire en cours
c'est ça le problème c'était l'affairé
de l' on courait n'est pas du tout
terminé il ne peut prendre position pour
donner son opinion
d'autant plus que là et ça c'est quand
même un deuxième fait il se trouve à
l'étranger
donc on a on en parlera exactement
mobilier donc on a rarement l'habitude
de voir un président de la république
parle et d'affaires intérieures j'allais
dire à l'étranger qui plus est est une
affaire qui est quand même extrêmement
sensible en cette affaire elle a déjà
donné lieu à beaucoup de commentaires
donc voilà donc le rappel de la cour de
cassation est déjà un rappel
institutionnels et ça ça me semble déjà
très important de le rappeler pour vous
il ya une forme de tentative d'ingérence
on peut interpréter cela comme ça alors
je viens de réécouter la séquence avec
vous le message est très clair c'est à
dire que ce que dit le président de la
république ne peut pas être mais
interprété pas du tout au contraire et
je pense qu'il est assez clair de quoi
il est question aujourd'hui il est
question de savoir si vous
oui ou non la cour de cassation qui fait
l'objet en fait un pourvoi
c'est un peu technique va décider de
renvoyer ou pas donc très au lit pendant
traoré devant une cour d'assises il ya
un premier arrêt qui a été rendu par la
chambre d'instruction qui a dit que pour
l'instant en l'état vu son état
psychiatrique
on ne pouvait pas le renvoyer devant une
cour d'assises ce que dit le président
de la république c'est qu'il ya un
besoin de procès je crois que le message
est clair quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la question qui est à l'étude
alors c'est vrai que cette affaire comme
vous l'avez déjà fait couler beaucoup
d'encre elle a créé la polémique c'est
vrai que le 19 décembre dernier on le
rappelle la chambre d'instruction de la
cour d'appel a rendu un arrêt très
discutée dans cette affaire tout le dit
aussi ultra sensible charges suffisantes
m'a été offert de ma part caractère
antisémite retenue mais l'assassin
pénalement irresponsable on évoquait
l'emprise du cannabis
c'est vrai que c'est un contexte
difficile dans avec une augmentation des
actes antisémites en france un besoin de
de justice
est ce qu'on peut comprendre que le
président tente effectivement de donner
un petit peu
voilà son avis sur la question où c'est
totalement inacceptable selon vous si
vous voulez en fait la question elle se
pose pas de cette manière la question
elle se pose sur à mon avis trois
aspects premier aspect c'est un problème
politique
quand on est à l'extérieur on ne parle
pas des affaires intérieures
ça c'est un premier problème deuxième
problème c'est sur un sur un plan
institutionnel notre constitution
demande au président de la république de
garantir l'indépendance une prise de
parole sur un dossier en cours est une
prise de parole qui ne peut pas être
neutre puisque le dossier n'est pas
terminée donc obligatoirement ça peut
s'apprécier comme une pression politique
c'est une femme une forme de
contamination politique d'un dossier
judiciaire et troisièmement
juridiquement parlant ça pose un trois
points c'est que ça donne de la
confusion
dans le débat public c'est à dire que
vous avez un dossier qui est déjà
extrêmement sensible parce qu en fait on
est sur un dossier en effet horrible
dans un contexte de montée d'actes
antisémites est donc évidemment que ce
dossier va crispé et va
si vous voulez dans l'opinion publique
obligatoirement ont essayé de donner un
aspect pour ou contre
donc encore plus dans ce genre de
dossier il ne faut pas prendre de parole
parce que la décision n'est pas
définitive
donc oui ça pose un vrai problème et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la cour de
cassation a fait ce rappel à l'ordre est
alors la porte parole du gouvernement
ces bêtes hendaia tenté de rétropédaler
en tout cas de d'assurer qu'il y avait
eu une mésinterprétation des propos du
président sur l' affaire halimi et qu'on
ne fait pas dans ce gouvernement de
pression sur qui que ce soit
on partage et enfin vous adhérez en tout
cas cette défense non je crois que les
propos du président sont très claires et
dire qu'il ya une mésinterprétation ce
serait dire que le président est confus
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse dire ça
après on comprend le contexte dans
lequel il s'exprime ce contexte n'est
pas anodin il n'est pas neutre il est en
israël on sait que quand même il ya une
très grande sensibilité de la communauté
juive sur ce dossier et on comprend
pourquoi ce contexte n'est pas neutre on
peut pas parler de mes interprétations
on met par contre c'est un vrai problème
c'est à dire que il ya de plus en plus
d'éruptions dans le du politique dans
les affaires judiciaires en france et il
est tout à fait normal et sain qu'on
rappelle les institutions je rappelle
aussi que
sur le plan donc de la constitution il
est garant de l'indépendance mais que la
seule personne dans notre code qui peut
s'exprimer parce que il ya quand même
des personnes qui peuvent s'exprimer
justement pour faire de la pédagogie sur
certains dossiers qui sont comme ça très
sensible c'est le procureur de la
république
donc nous avons quand même des personnes
qui peuvent s'exprimer sur des dossiers
en cours et notre code de procédure
pénal dit réclamant que c'est le
procureur de la république qui peut le
faire est-ce que selon vous il y a des
précédents où c'est sous l'hère macro
les choses semblent s'envenimer on
connaît les relations difficiles qu'ils
avaient
notamment nicolas sarkozy avec une
partie de la magistrature
est ce que c'est un fait surprenant pour
un président de la république alors il
ya déjà bien sûr il ya des précédents on
va pas dire que c'est un fait historique
ce qui est quand même assez nous c'est
que ça se fasse à l'étranger
ça c'est quand même assez particulier
nous on a déjà eu des irruptions du
politique sur des affaires judiciaires
et c'est d'ailleurs bien le problème de
notre système
en france c'est de reclassifier qui fait
quoi qui a droit de faire quoi et c'est
un problème d'institutions je rappelle
d'ailleurs à ce propos qu'il ya une
commission d' enquête qui vient de
s'ouvrir la demande d'ailleurs de la
france insoumise sur la question de
l'indépendance de la justice
donc on voit bien que cette thématique
elle est posée sur la table en france
particulièrement en france et que il
faut clarifier absolument nos
institutions sur ce point là
comment le vivent les magistrats ce type
de pressions quel est l'impact sur sur
un professionnel la magistrature moi je
parlerais pas de pression parce que pour
parler de pression il faut pouvoir être
impressionné et je ne sais pas si les
magistrats de la cour de cassation sont
impressionnés par ce qui a été dit je
pense que c'est plutôt un rappel général
si vous voulez de ce qui peut se faire
et de ce qui ne peut pas se faire et
d'ailleurs la communication de la cour
de cassation
c'est ce qu'elle dit a dit laissez nous
travailler de manière sereinement
je pense que les magistrats et je
l'espère sont tout à fait aptes à
résister à cette pression mais c'est
vrai que c'était c'est important de le
rappeler et on ne devrait pas avoir à le
rappeler mnm la crau qui rappelle que la
question de l'antisémitisme pour lui et
celle de la république ont rappelé il ya
un contexte très émotif très sensible
autour de ces questions nous dit et
magistrats ne cède pas aux pressions
mais tout de même ils lisent la presse
il écoute les informations
comment peuvent-ils percevoir cette
émotion dans un pays
ils n'en sont pas moins un citoyen on
vous dit on lit la presse on vit dans
notre société on le voit aussi mais
encore une fois à la question de
l'antisémitisme qui est un vrai problème
puisque je rappelle on a une croissance
d actes antisémites et pas et pas que et
pas que d'ailleurs donc c'est un vrai
sujet c'est d'abord un sujet politique
avant d'être un sujet judiciaire c'est à
dire qu'il ya déjà des leviers
politiques pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme
j'allais dire que nous quand on arrive
c'est presque trop tard c'est que les
actes ont déjà eu lieu donc nous on est
là pour les sanctionner
mais du côté du politique plein de
choses à faire et le président de la
république a tout à fait raison de s'en
emparer simplement louise qui doit faire
c'est du politique
merci en tout cas avait pris sa brugère
secrétaire général adjoint du syndicat
national des magistrats est fou d'avoir
apporté votre opinion en direct sur rt
france persia merci